nothing symbolizes democratic government
more than the vote behind me is the
polling place where I vote on Election
Day on Election Day there's a long line
outside the door Election Day is the
last day of the campaign in the case of
the United States is the last day of a
very long campaign we have marathon
campaigns that's different than European
campaigns they last a few weeks in the
United States they last four months and
once one reason for that is that we have
primary elections candidates have to run
first in the primary and if they win
then they run in the general election
European democracies do not have
primaries American campaigns differ also
in other ways if you're watching an
American campaign on television you'll
see lots and lots of televised political
ads some democracies prohibit or ban the
use of televised ads others restrict the
time period in which they can be shown
another way in which American elections
differ is that there are a lot more
expensive a federal campaign now in the
United States will cost more than a
billion dollars that's 20 times what a
campaign would cost in Germany or
Britain or Spain make no mistake there
is an American way of conducting
elections